thank you yasir yes we are indeed with a
very happy victory of today's round anna
congratulations thank you you know tatef
quite well you've played her so many
times did you ever play her in a match
situation
no never i think it's it's very new uh
format and how did you approach this
match
okay i prepared so this was something
new i saw that she played in blitz this
variation of bishop d2 and i just
decided to
to do something about it yeah and it's
she surprised me with move c5 after
bishop d2 c5
you both were kind of uh taking your
time trying to understand the position
did you see this before did you analyze
no no
i forgot or i didn't see
take us through the game and don't you
feel like you're taking over
uh probably
right now when i played just six seasons
yes yes okay it's like and here
e5
so here we're thinking queen c2 but then
g6 like in the game and i need to space
for my rook of course of course queen c2
is more natural move but then after
yes here queer queen to g6 i don't have
this maneuver this i need the square c3
square for my knight
like when your knight is coming back you
anticipated the game yeah yes yes i saw
97 for sure which i was quite happy
that's why i played queen v1
and rook and that's the whole point of
your maneuver yes and c3 to c2 so your
queen cannot occupy the square
uh that is a very nice uh idea
and you get to a position
at this point how are you feeling a
little bit better yourself i had like um
i thought like i have some pressure but
she was about to equalize and i don't
know why she didn't play queen d6 the
most natural move could be sex and then
or like exchanging everything right
bring the rooks to the scene so maybe i
still have like slightly i don't know
like uh
in the game it's easier to play with
white
that she has allowed you instead
after this after this six i already had
feeling that i have advantage
exactly
and then here it's kind of like she
mobilized her rook
on d6 it wasn't
completely clear still at this point
but king g7 kim just said on this is
just terrible yeah
and now
uh
okay we had here like two minutes and
yes yeah this is uh
tatia was already blitzing like last ten
moves so it's difficult to play such
position for black when you are
defending
i see
and i think it's i already had
experience playing with this time
control so i think it was
i already knew how to play how to
distribute time right so uh your your uh
feelings about the format this double
double match elimination okay i can tell
you that from my point of view it's a
lot of pressure when you're playing
match but then i think it's like
spectators like chess fans will benefit
like really a lot and i think it's this
is great idea
and double elimination this is also good
because you will see the same players
already lost right continue playing and
i i think it's so it's it's a very good
idea
now the fact that you have a second life
does it make it a bit more bearable that
tension in the first match
say it again the fact that you have a
second life even if you lose one mesh
then you still get the second life yes
is it more bearable the tension in the
first match yes i think so i think so
and also this is not like what do you do
with this players they will go home yeah
yeah
you give them a chance and i think it's
a very good idea
good excellent anna good luck tomorrow
we're looking forward to see your game
thank you anna thank you for joining us
yeah and she will be defending with the
black pieces remember a draw will be
enough for